hey everybody thanks for coming back for
more making of buildings which I know
I've been doing that in pretty much the
entire first episode but there are still
two more buildings that I need to finish
before this entire entrance building is
actually done and before in the second
half in this video we can start on the
path work of the entrance Plaza which is
really cool we're going to do some fun
stuff with that but first I need to
finish this but I do think that this
building that I'm working on in
particular right now it's really
interesting and probably even my
favorite of the entire main street of
course not counting the big entrance
gates just because it's actually based
on the reference and most of these
buildings were pretty much just winging
it I just started building buildings
without any kind of reference material
and started our new time-lapse on every
building and if it went good just keep
on recording that time-lapse and keep
working on the building until it looked
good and that was pretty much the
approach to most of these things but
this one is actually made with a
reference and it's very far from my
recreation but it is very heavily
inspired by a castle in real life it's
my favorite castle in the world actually
it's the palest castle in Romania in
sanaya if I recall correctly which is a
really beautiful castle and it's got
this really interesting blend of like
the lower parts of the castle which are
all stone with very beige looking colors
on the accents and the top part of the
building which has that timber framework
with I think a lot of redwood and very
fancy roofs as well and it's a really
beautiful class one I just wanted to get
a bit of inspiration from it and get
that as a small hint into the tower on
the side here because I didn't want to
keep those two castle towers on the ends
of both wings something like the big
arms that kind of create you as you go
into the park I'm not sure if that
really makes any sense but that's just
the idea of how I set up these buildings
and at the end of like both of those
large wings I wanted to have a tower too
well just make everything look pretty
cool
was the basic idea and I think this is a
kind of style which fits into the rest
of the buildings quite nicely because
obviously I did want to have a different
style and color palettes to each of
these buildings while at the same time
making sure that it fits in with the
rest of the buildings as well and this
is just a style which I think fits in
quite nicely but also one sort of idea
about this entire entrance which I
haven't really mentioned before is that
it's also sort of a tests of styles it's
not just the test of the building pieces
in the game because it's obviously a
very good opportunity to get used to
what the pieces are and what you can do
with them and everything but it's also
bit of a test of what styles I can get
back later in the park like say this
particular colour palettes of this one
building works out very well or the way
that the tower is set up with the roofs
of one building it works so well that I
figure you might as well use it in the
rest of the park so many of these
buildings are kind of like little
prototypes of styles that I might try
later on in the park and I think for
this building in particular I'm going to
try something similar to it in the rest
of the park as well where it'll be a
building that stands on its own as a
restaurant or as a station for a ride
something like that just because I think
it's a style that I really love about it
just with those like two halves of
having the bottom half be that very
light stone beige-ish colour accented
part and having the top part being a
more Alpine looking timber framework and
the basic shape of this building is very
simple in this case having the tower at
the very end of it and having some of
the roofs that come out on the sides and
some different heights and different
arches and everything to look at make it
look a little bit more dynamic and
interesting than just a single flat wall
and that is very basically the approach
of these buildings here I was actually I
actually think one of the things that I
would mention is a small tip at least I
really like it is instead of using the
planks to get the wooden planks in on
buildings use those square pillows I
think they have a little bit of a like
better texture they blend into each
other a bit more but also they're a bit
thicker so you can like get them out of
the wall as much as you can and just by
having them stick out of the building
they just pop out a little more or a
little bit more there we go which you
know it doesn't make too much of a
difference but it does make a little bit
of a difference it does make it look a
bit nicer I think and also what it helps
with is that sometimes you want to cover
a window like you want to cover the
borders of a window because you don't
really like them and you want to use the
wooden colour instead and if you use
those pillars you can bring them out as
much as you need to to cover up stuff I
just really love that the sort of thick
look that it has to it and as for the
strategy of making the timber on this
it's just really simple some beams
around the windows to just make sure
that that's all good and filling up the
other empty spaces with horizontal beams
and that is just about it there's not
too much diagonal beam action going on
just a little bit on the tower because I
have quite a large surface area to cover
with wid over there and a few diagonal
supports on the wooden supports that
need to support the roof just to give
that you know extra support but that's
really just about everything and aside
from that I just wanted to add a little
bit more detail to the building by
adding those baskets and adding some
window boxes I think they're actually
planters or yeah these are actually the
planter is actually just like using the
planter is a bit more than using the
actual window boxes because they're just
slightly larger which I guess works a
little bit better but yeah that's it for
that building we're already moving on to
the next building which is a bit of a
filler I have to be very honest these
men these mill buildings are just not as
interesting as the ones on the side and
this one in particular is just a simple
sort of straightforward building with a
tower on it just to give it a bit more
Flair than the simple straightforward
building than it is but it's just it's
not really anything too special I do
think it's yeah I think it's the only
building with a dark warm most of these
buildings have a very light brick wall
actually all of them have a
brick wall and the stucco parts for the
higher sections of the building but this
is the only building with like a wall
that's very dark and accents that are
lighter than it I think usually I want
to change like the colors of pieces so
that you have either dark walls with
light accents or light walls with dark
accents and most of these buildings have
just very light walls with like very
dark corner stones or pillars or windows
over them but in this case I think it
might as well reverse those walls
so this is going to be a very dark brick
building kind of a a Dutch looking
texture on the bricks as well with some
very light details on top of it and that
Tower which is like the only thing that
really sticks out from it and gives it a
little bit of extra height as well I
guess it just made sure that the
building is at a complete Wallflower
anyway I wanted to skip forward in the
time lapse there a little bit because
this is not the most interesting
building and you might notice that I'm
adding like an extra bit of foliage
around it just because it's not that
interesting and just by adding that
extra bit of detail add it at least
comes out a bit more like any boring
building that's just really
straightforward and just has Falls but
that I still want to have a lot of
detail on I pretty much fell with
baskets and flower boxes which is super
lazy I know but it mostly works and
especially because I wanted to get us
like a charming atmosphere into it it
really helps to get as much foliage on
the buildings as you can but the next
thing that I wanted to do this is
something which I was failing with for
quite a while here is make the planters
for the trees I have been planning to
have trees around this Plaza for quite a
while I do want to place them very
selectively though it's something which
you don't really see on camera but it's
something which I was playing with for
very long time just because I wanted to
have trees to just make the plaza look a
bit more alive add some greenery to it
but on the other hand I also wanted to
make sure that they don't block out any
like sites then I really wanted to
preserve so they're gonna be quite
sparse there's not going to be too many
of them
and especially here I wanted to keep
them very much on the side so they just
kind of come out from over the buildings
but they don't really cover up any views
from any place like you should still be
able to see all of the different facades
as you approach the park and a bit of
detailing over here as well because some
of these buildings didn't have much
detailing and now we're pretty much into
the big parts of what is going to be the
plaza and a bit of my like path work
experiments if you will in this case you
might know that I've been renting about
the way that paths work in the game I
think the path system isn't that bad the
only problem with it is that many theme
parks have these very large open plazas
that really flow through an area and
have a lot of like different colors and
shapes and illustrations on the path
work as well and that's something that
you can barely get into Planet coasters
and that's why I wanted to really try in
this Plaza and if it works I might as
well use it in the rest of the park as
well consider this a bit of a prototype
as well so the plan here is to basically
get a very wide large concrete field in
the middle of all of these paths to kind
of make it look as if this is one very
large plaza instead of a big grassy area
and that's basically the first part of
the plan which took a lot of placing all
of these different buildings very
precisely to get in the curves around
the plaza but that's not going to be
everything that would be quite boring so
obviously I'll also add some flower
boxes and planters lot of path elements
like benches and litter bins and
lampposts as well in the future but
that's not everything either there's two
more things that I wanted to do to dress
this up a little bit nicer and one of
them is happening over here which was
adding a like sidewalk to the side with
a balustrade as well having paths that
actually overhang over the water and
that you can actually have some fences
next to it is pretty much impossible at
least you can't get them functional
but you can get other thing that really
looks like it's a like it's sort of
promenade next to the water or a bird
vibe you will and that's why I wanted to
try it over here so I'm just getting a
very simple roof in at this point to
make the part itself and a Bella
straight to make the fence on the side
of that now each of these pieces is a
separate building to make sure that it
really follows a curve or the path which
is the one thing that I would say about
this it'll be hard to do this kind of
thing without already existing paths as
a guideline to know where to go and I am
definitely really happy that I have
these paths on the side just so that
people can at least walk somewhat close
to these sidewalks here but um yeah I
just wanted to get this in here to make
it look like there is an actual path
that really goes over the water and that
you can sit on a bench and look at the
water from even if it's not even
functional so uh that's what we're doing
over here
now the very last thing that I wanted to
do here which I'll get into after I do
this bit of rock work and a bit of
terraforming is something that I've been
wanting to try in this came for a very
long time but that just has been pretty
much impossible just because of the
pieces in the fact that there wasn't any
recolor ability before but now we do and
I think it's about time to start making
some path artwork and if you're a very
longtime viewer of me and you still
remember some roller coast like in three
videos what I used to do way too much in
roller coastering three is get like all
kinds of artwork into the paths like
curving colorful shapes or making stars
or things just any kind of thing that
looks cool on a path and I wanted to try
something similar to this in planet
coaster since we've got the new pieces
and we can finally recolor things and I
figured just by sinking these things
very like slowly and lowly into the
paths you can actually make some cool
shape so what I'm doing over here is
trying to make a compass out of these
different castle elements
and it's quite simple to make actually
just kind of sink them into the ground
and make sure you turn snapping off and
place them a little bit diagonally so
they have that line in the middle where
they both disappear into each other and
they also have that slight diagonal line
so they do sort of go toward the end
into a very stretched out triangle shape
and that's why I was going for and the
last thing that I wanted to get into
which is still unfinished and which
might still be a work in progress until
I get back to this place at some point
in the future and start changing some
things is the large ring around the star
of the compass which just turned out to
be a very hard job just because it's
hard to get a perfect circle in and it's
a glove Tryon error to get that right
and I didn't feature all of it but
you'll see in a minute how it turned out
in the end it just took a lot of time to
get the perfect circle in so skipping
forward a little bit this is what it
looks like in the end we have the
compass in the center there I added a
few plants around it just to make it
look a bit more fancy and a few trees on
the side here and that's just about all
of the foliage that I'll be adding in
the plaza the next thing that I wanted
to do is get custom lights and I wanted
to make these quite fancy as well not
just because well the in-game lights are
super common and will get pretty tiring
to see those all the time I also think
you know this is the big entrance parts
of the park and usually in points you
see these really fancy like super tall
lampposts around the entrance parts so I
wanted to get something like that in
here as well so I'm making a quick post
with a bunch of decoration trying some
stuff actually think some of those signs
will be very good to use as fences at
some point in future but I'm not going
to spoil too much of that so yeah it's
just a post with a couple of lamps on it
and that's really just about it and that
will be copied throughout this entrance
plus I might also use it it
the main street of the park or even like
lake that I'm gonna have in the center
of the park but we'll see how useful
this piece is going to be just wanted to
have it to add a bit more in life to the
plaza and make sure that you know it's
not a big dead concrete space is the
danger with very large parts is that
they become like very dead and empty and
wide stretches of concrete desert and
that's just about the last thing that I
wanted to happen here and also I'm
adding these quick cute lamps on the
posts on the balustrade
I was figuring for quite a while that I
might add some big lamps on the side
here but I just like the looks of these
very small lamps on those like
balustrade posts way too much so that's
what we're going for and a couple of
finishing touches on the paths as well I
might want to save all of these things
as blueprints that we'll make while
future pikes bit more easy and I might
even upload them we'll just see about
that but yeah just adding a few more
planters in here to get more foliage
into the plaza which is always very good
and last but not least some of the path
elements so there are a few benches over
here and moving some of these topiaries
here because I had like yeah I had six
on one side and five on the other side
for quite a while there and I'm not
really any OCD kind of person as you
might notice by the fact that this is
not a very symmetrical Plaza but that
was not very great so I had to get rid
of that and also wanted to make a very
quick planter on the side here but that
didn't really work out so I ended up
just putting the very simple things in
there and the very last thing that I'm
doing really just to finish off the look
of this Plaza and make it look as if
it's you know almost in a finished Park
to just get an idea of what this entire
thing is going to look like with
everything around it just a bit of
finishing foliage and here I discovered
one of my new favorite things in the
game which is like that let that very
low light brownish Bush which looks a
lot like dead grass and if you sink it
into the ground or water you can really
make it look like some swampy grass
or read like things a few remember back
from Monaco sticking three that were
actually these the grass pieces that
were like supposed to be desert grass or
beach grass but it worked out really
well in the water as well and this sort
of gives a similar effect kind of makes
it look a bit more swampy and gets that
good transition from the water into the
forest on the side here anyway that's it
for the time-lapse I'm getting into the
real time point now right so let's have
some real time talk for a second this is
what the plaza looks like and I think
this is from writes in the middle it's
not perfect but this is basically the
idea of what I wanted to get at as you
get into the park this is basically the
site that greets you I also do like how
the curve of the buildings kind of gives
you the impression that it's like kind
of slightly curved camera as well even
though there's definitely not the case
at least that's not how the fov is set
up but yeah this is what it looks like
this is the entrance and it is and it's
more or less finished State at this
point I might get back to it in the
future and touch up some stuff but um
this is just the idea of what I wanted
to do also at some point in a future
when actually get the castle in the
middle of the park you'll see that like
slightly rise up from the back of these
buildings which is one of the reasons
why I wanted to have an arch with like
an opening in the middle of it just so
you can keep your eyes on the wing even
as you get into the pike so um let's get
a better look at some of this stuff I do
have to say I'll get like a real proper
look into all of these things when I get
into like cinematic parts of videos
which is probably gonna come all the way
at the end of this series when I
actually finish it and get a cinematic
video out there but um this is a bit
more of a backstage look as you can see
I have added these backstage buildings
to the things since this is just one
building actually these are just empty
husks of facades even though they kind
of look like real for detailed buildings
they really aren't much in a disney-like
way if you kind of look from the back it
more or less destroys the magic
so this is like one big entrance
building actually which is going to go
into a very small Main Street over here
at least that is the future planning
it's not going to be a very large Main
Street it is going to be a bit
disney-esque with having the Main Street
and the big entrance in all that but it
is going to be a couple of buildings so
already start splitting off the Main
Street just about this point I think so
that we have enough space to have a like
very large walkway over here with a
large lake in the middle of the park
which is what I really want to do so
we'll also have some fun like
interaction between the lake and the
paths in the future which is always cool
and after that Lake or behind the lake I
should say will have the big weenie of
the park which is going to be the castle
which works kind of in a sense like what
a combination almost of the universal
parks and the Disney parks because the
universal islands of adventure of course
has that large lake in the middle of it
and I'm pretty sure Hollywood studios
those too but after that we actually
have a more Disney like well big castle
which will be good to have a large
castle at the end of the Main Street
that sort of thing that you really walk
toward but you also get the fun part of
having the reflection of the castle in
the water and having a cool lake to walk
around in the middle of the park and
that are also more or less be the hub of
the park and then the rest of the path
work is going to be all of the spokes
that go into the different parts
well maybe have the African section over
here but it's probably going to end up
being over here I'm not really sure
about that yet since I wanted to do it
somewhat geographically accurate but
we're already starting with Europe here
and Europe is gonna pretty much cut
through the middle of this park so that
would mean that Africa would get
squished on the side we'll probably get
America over here which will probably
become South America I could maybe
probably get a bit of North America in
there as well but we'll see how that's
gonna work out I don't have any concrete
plans for that or anything
and probably the Asian section over here
which is mostly going to be the the
Japanese Chinese kind of Asian but maybe
I can go into some fun stuff that I
never tried before like Indonesian or
Indian and things like that I mean they
are very underrated themes same goes for
a South American theme that is something
which I've never tried before and I've
also never tried an African theme so
those are definitely things that I want
to try and well just see how it goes
anyway that's it for today so thank you
guys so much for watching it so far and
I hope to see you guys next time in
which I'll try to make the main street
and see how far we'll come with the park
planning bye bye